[Music]
hey what's up you guys i'm denny direct
oh thanks for joining us for a daily
denny live and how fitting that on new
music friday i got the scoop on what I
will guarantee will be your new summer
anthem and the person who is behind it
please welcome Chantel Jeffries like I
just mentioned you dropped a fiber new
single I'm telling you guys right now
we're gonna play a little bit for you in
just a moment but it's like a summer
joint I've ever heard it congratulations
wait is the name of it right I mean how
do you feel now that it's finally
finally out in the world you know when
you say it's a summer anthem that's
amazing I actually made it in summer
last summer so I've been listening to it
for like 10 months I mean I still love
it so much I'm happy feedback everyone
likes it and I'm like so excited I was
telling you it's like that song I'm
gonna be playing on a loop in my car you
know with the windows down like
thankfully we're in California so it's
gonna be good weather to be jamming to
your song I'm alright exactly is that
what you imagine when you're like
prancing it exactly well that in the
club that's so much fun
guys Chantel we'll be here for the next
10 minutes or so so if you have any
questions leave them in the comment
section we'll get here to the iPad but
like you mentioned people already eating
this song up and it's ready number three
on the dance turrets on iTunes I mean
that's gotta feel good yes it's really
exciting I mean I'm up there with the
Zed and Calvin Harris Simon come on and
I'm like trying to pass something that I
said that yeah and those are two of my
favorite songs right now so it would be
right there with them is just like I
think you could pass him has only been
out for a couple hours so you know we
got the whole day ahead you know you
know we should check by then in this
interview er exactly right if you guys
haven't heard the new track yet wait we
got a little taste for you right right
now take a listen
I fall why don't I just text my axe pull
up 104 l89 things I know you got a man
buddy this [ __ ] now says me love you
what'd I tell ya I mean come on that's a
fly and that's off sit and worry right
there on the feature um I mean off say
he's a busy guy so of course part of me
goes how did you lock that down
oh it just kind of happened through your
like the labels and everything that
someone actually I played the song for
all my friends and industry and just
like close friends and I tried some
different people on it and someone like
a couple people were like you should get
off set on this I think he would kill it
I think he sounds you know would sound
great on this and I thought it would be
a great way to kind of expand like what
he does because my song isn't it's not
like a typical hip-hop song it's
actually like a French house inspired it
has higher BPM so I think like the
juxtaposition between War II and him is
just great because for a more on the
singing and the iron b-side and then him
it's just like that amazing rap and you
just put it together and it's just and
then like it just works together yeah
they both crushed it on this song what
was it like collaborating with offset I
really loved when I got the verse back
going through it and like decoding each
bar and like figuring out what they
meant cuz all my friends what does that
mean was that mean I like just put my
rap genius cap on so what is the
inspiration behind his uh his rhymes
there I mean it's just like he's like
doing things it's like the whole thing
you know yeah you know it's on rap
genius
I got a rap genius right now sure I got
a doubt did you get to be in the studio
with him when he recorded it no he was
not in LA when he did it
so busy obviously this baby away and
he's you know Coachella this that yeah
he's really busy so he was in here but
he carted be about to welcome a little
Bharti you know a little baby Bharti up
in the world what kind of dad you think
off said will be I think baby's gonna be
dressed very flock right I love that so
for those who may be unfamiliar with you
you're also a DJ and it was awesome
because you spun at some Coachella
parties you actually I found out you
also spun at the Vanity Fair Oscars well
what was that like do you get is it like
nerve-wracking kind of having to perform
for a celeb crowd like that I think it's
really cool because it's you know since
it's more of an intimate thing like they
can actually come up and talk to you and
then I will play like all of these
different Easter egg songs that I have
that people might not know we're cool
remixes that my other DJ friends I've
done and sent to me and they'll always
ask go what is this um what does that
song and like I'll tell them and it's
great you know because I love that's my
favorite part of going out I'm like
she's a me everything when I hear a song
I don't know me totally like original
remix yeah yeah I've actually done that
I was in Vegas and this is DITA they're
called mighty mad and he yeah yeah he
does like he's an amazing DJ and I went
up after psycho I went to meet him and
talk he gave me a USB of like all of his
stuff like all his remixes you know
really great so that doesn't bother you
when people come up to the booth know
it's like it just yeah it just depends
like what I'm just sometimes I'm like in
them like actually mixing them to songs
and I can't talk right that's I can but
yeah I know I don't mind like talking
about the song who was the most famous
person that came up to you at that Danny
I honestly I don't even know yeah I'm in
the zone and I don't even really like
I'm sure it was like some really
important people I was like totally they
don't want to mess up on a nerve I was a
little bit nervous on that one I was
what's amazing about that parties they
don't let press in there so like did you
get to see people turn up there oh yeah
oh yeah right they're having a good time
yeah
that was well for the actual party after
the one after the Oscars that I wanted
to was the best part it was so good
that's so fun yeah I want your life girl
really hard walking around that long
dress oh oh oh I bet you look good up
there to here like yeah this is my Oscar
dress but I'm also killing it right now
on this boot um now speaking of
Coachella you were spending there of
course you know you were snapped
arm-in-arm with the weekend and of
course the rumor well rumor mill went
crazy what was the deal there we're just
really good friends I'm so affection
with all my friends like I was like
literally running around Coachella happy
you know ever just having a good time
and yeah so I'm like crazy about one
photo and like it's really one snap of
an entire weekend just like mine start
racing yeah of course he was headlining
at Coachella of course they wanted to do
that baby we're just really good friends
he's a great guy yeah I've known him for
years just through mutual friends and
stuff but yeah it must be frustrating
cuz you were also linked to Bieber it's
like who's also at Coachella do you guys
run into each other I pass man hey that
does this treachery no I know I was
every time I'd leave go tell him like
Bobby Wade knows is black and I even
realized everyone was dying and I'm just
like I thought I was fine but apparently
have the black lung and I was felt like
I was in Zoolander no I went both week
is this year and it was even worse
I actually got sick just from all of
that yeah I breathe and all that does
but yeah do you and beeps keep in touch
at all we're friends you see him around
sometimes yeah yeah he's a great guy too
yeah I mean you're obviously killing it
already
brink of a huge career you're so
talented is the frustrating for you do
you pay attention to any of those
headlines and those relationship rumors
that kind of like run online I mean it's
there so you see it but I try to like
focus my energy elsewhere cuz then in
the day like I have things to do and I
don't want to like let things [ __ ] my
mood and like cloud my focus and they're
just kind of like one of those things
where it just comes and goes and you
know it's like a wave when it comes it
comes buddy you know it's gonna go it's
just like how it is I've got the chin
you're like I just focusing on my music
right well speaking of your music I
actually learned that you are a mathlete
as well right yeah well I was a mouthful
it was about well in my school's called
math counts I have my little math counts
lunchbox I always kept using it through
college because the only lunchbox that I
had and really go out buying a lunchbox
I think walking around College
counseling you know like you got the
creative side of the brain and also that
other side like I don't I'm so bad at
math and I hear you kind of apply it
when you're producing music how do you
how do you do that it's it's just like
the sequencing and when you look at like
a production when you're producing a
song and you look at the programming
it's a graph and it's you can see how
the notes are and like sometimes before
I even hear and I'm like I'll be like no
no no this note needs to go up because
it's just like you know how it's going
to sound once it plays just with all the
instruments and yeah I think it's
everything you you know can be applied
elsewhere of you if you're if you think
about it that you're good at math like
or you use this like wire here why don't
need a derivative it's just like so then
I'm like well now that I know the graphs
of sine waves the cosine wave functions
like all these things I don't know
anything they just sound I don't know
anything
the sound waves of the every sound has
like a frequency so like a wave will
play if you play like a certain note and
they all have a different it's like a
sine wave of cosine wave a circle like
there's different things that are
created you can actually make shapes
Bassnectar he does like a crazy thing
with his sets where he creates a
butterfly out of sound waves well on an
oscillator so it's just really really
amazing I'm just like wow it's it's math
you know what this is a sign for all you
kids watching that math is important you
can't apply it outside of the classroom
you can't you're changing my thoughts
all day I'm like okay right that's true
you should know how to do some math
Ashley from YouTube has a question she
wants to know do you have any more plans
for any more collabs yes I'm pretty much
all my songs will have globs for now
what cuties like what artists are you
working on or who are gonna appear on
the EP I mean obviously borays on some
more songs but the rest are gonna be
little things I just love Easter eggs
like offset was that yeah you know
nobody knew everyone knew about the song
they knew about we're being on the song
but then they didn't know about office
until last minute so they good nice
little surprise yeah without giving the
names of ways or anyone you were like
really really excited to get like
someone you've been dying to work with
there's yeah there's people that I've
grown up listening to in condom just
like always like love their music yeah I
love that
okay every from facebook says our weight
is lint on so many levels he didn't have
a question just went to you it's that
good
Alan wants to know what are your
favorite lyrics in the song and wait if
I got it you got it
my prayer problems my problems yeah
that's right that's a relationship for
you right you take on that burden you
can I have to so on the daily Danny on
Fridays we highlight some new tracks cuz
it is Friday and a bunch of new stuff
comes out your of course feature but I
wanted to go through three of them I
also drop them maybe get your opinion on
them you know you mentioned people you
look looked up to were you big fan of
Christina Aguilera broke girl yeah well
she's back after six I saw that that was
happening but I haven't heard it yet
because I was at my party all night and
now I've been doing this stuff this
morning so I haven't heard yet but I've
I always make a point to sit down and
just listen to all the songs I did hear
the I love that well you know what
you're in luck actually because we do
have a little snippet of Christina's new
song called accelerate featuring ty
dolla sign and 2 Chainz the video is
kind of gnarly to guys take a look
[Music]
from dirty to glitter huh funny because
the juxtaposition of wait and accelerate
like my songs about slowing down and
wait that songs about accelerating and
picking up you know what it's like the
yin to the yang right alright because
she looks good though I love the glitter
I'm sparkly no stripping download yeah
there she used to be a lot of makeup and
glam and stuff I kind of like this D
Christina so we'll see where she goes
with that but you heard this next one
Travis Scott watch featuring Kanye West
and lil Uzi vert the snippet we have is
actually Kanye's verse because I don't
know when he wrote this but he's really
hitting some it's the stuff he's been in
the news about lately you guys take a
listen real quick I know I playing
fields I got off my main pills
met my wife he stay close she know I'm
on my bezos opioid addiction pharmacies
the real trapped
sometimes I feel trapped or with no feel
jak1 years
sunken place they don't want me to
change down take a run in place I need
someone that's to make this drink
because you don't understand just a
[ __ ] ratio to satisfy real drunk
guess what never trust a bartender dad
don't drink bit like did he record this
yesterday you know yeah I mean he sounds
amazing that's thing I I mean he touched
on a really good point there well I
liked it when he was saying about the
the pharmacies and that OBO just because
you know it's like you want to use your
platform just spread awareness on
certain things and I think you know I
really all eyes are on him right now so
did you watch him on TMZ live that's
where he kind of addressed that opioid
addiction and the fact that he thinks
like America's too drugged I didn't see
it but I saw like the means or not means
but like them yeah for sure it's super
relevant you know Kris Jenner was
actually on Ellen today and saying like
everything he does is with good
intention so I think you make a good
point like I think he's just trying to
get like a point across to his fans you
know all love from Kanye's what he likes
to say right this next one is from your
homie Diplo he teamed up with labyrinth
and SIA under the moniker LSD and they
got a new trippy video for their single
genius guys take a look
[Music]
[Music]
like I wanted my video to be a cartoon
did you really like yeah I love it
like I'm cartoons especially ones like
that are so cool yeah I really opens up
parts of your brain that you don't got
to use all right I think I hope
hopefully this means actually more music
from the three of them which I love them
together I was not expecting that but it
gave me some broad city advice which I
like are we expecting the full video
from you for wait yes how long do we
have to wait for it you don't know yeah
well you know your friends actually just
recorded a bunch of home videos of them
singing your song listening yeah yeah
must be so morning I just saw that what
kind of it's like all your homies yeah I
was like a surprise like by my team yeah
oh that's awesome
and then Coachella and stuff okay so how
does it feel to get their support oh
it's amazing you know I've had so much
support from my friends it means so much
to me but they've been there for the
whole process that's up so they're like
excited too and they've all been
listening to a song and now like they
could listen to it all the time like
happy yeah a lot of people on YouTube
were actually asking if you're really
friends with Jake Paul I saw the video
no who's so surprised by that honestly I
was yeah but I mean like thank you first
for sure yeah well you know you have a
huge presence on YouTube too it's just
the community supported community I
think right they don't yeah yeah a
couple more questions coming in real
quick before we wrap up Lauren's asking
when did you first start DJing I started
DJing about two and a half years ago
yeah and I started producing it about a
year ago that's wild and they turned out
something like wait Mike come on that's
so sick I love that what can we expect
from the rest of the EPS at the is
weight kind of like the vibe that we can
expect from the rest of the records well
I feel like I have a little bit of
they're all kind of summer records
there's a couple that are European vibe
and there's a couple that are more like
it
kind of like an island ich by but I get
most of my influence from like European
kind of house music and like just
different like my travel and I hear
things and I like to incorporate that
yeah I mean you're like you mentioned
you're at those clubs and like shows
damage that literally you're inspired
yeah I love that before we go what do
you want to tell your fans we're about
to light you are literally your day ones
supporting you with this single and I'm
sure gonna be stick around for a bit
yes no I literally thank you guys so
much honestly I've got in so many
comments from you guys about you were
there like before I even started
producing you were there when like the
song the little clips I first put out
and then I hope that you guys like it
and so far the feedbacks good - thank
you kids I'm telling you guys you're
gonna be bumping it all weekend long
I'll summer long and you can download
and stream wait right now we'll be
waiting for that video though I can't
read it
thank you so much for coming are you
guys that's it for this week we'll be
back on Monday with a new daily denne
until then just have a good weekend all
right cheers guys bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]